الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
اللاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله ان شاء
الله شاء
الله استقيم
واعتدلوا
الف
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقال الذي لا يرجون
لقاءنا لولا انزل علينا
الملائكه او نرى
ربنا لقد استكبروا في انفسهم وعتوا عتوا
كبيرا يوم يرون
الملائكه لا بشرى يومئذ
للمجرمين ويقول
حجرا
محجورا وقدمنا الى ما عملوا من
عمل فجعلناه
هباء
منثورا اصحاب
الجنه يومئذ خير مستقرا واحسن
مقيلا ويوم تشقق
السماء الغمام ونزل
الملائكه ونزل
الملائكه
تنزيلا الملك يومئذ الحق
للرحمن وكان يوما على
الكافرين
عسيرا ويوم يعض الظالم على يديه يقول يا
ليتني اتخذت مع الرسول
سبيلا يا ويلت ليتني لم اتخذ فلانا
خليلا لقد اضلني عن الذكر بعد اذ
جاءني وكان الشيطان
للانسان
خذولا وقال الرسول يا رب ان قومي اتخذوا
هذا قران
مهجورا وكذلك جعلنا لكل نبي عدوا من
المجرمين وكفى بربك
هاديا
ونصيرا وقال الذين كفروا لولا نزل عليه
القران جمله
واحده كذلك لنثبت
به فؤادك ورتلناه
ترتيلا ولا ياتونك بمثل الا جئناك بالحق
واحسن
تفسيرا الذين يحشرون على وجوههم الى
جهنم
اولئك شر
مكانا واضل
سبيلا
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد اتينا موسى كتاب وجعلنا معه
اخاه هارون
وزيرا فقلنا اذهبا الى القوم الذي كذبوا
باياتنا
فدمرناهم
تدميرا وقوم نوح لما كذبوا الرسل
اغرقناهم
وجعلناهم
للناس ايه واعتدنا للظالم
عذابا اليما وعادا وثمود واصحاب الرس
وقرونا بين ذلك
كثيرا
وكلا ضربنا له الامثال وكلا تبرنا
تتبيرا ولقد اتوا على القريه التي امطرت
مطر السوء افلم يكونوا يرونها
بل كانوا لا يرجون
نشورا واذا راوك ان
يتخذونك الا
هزوا اهذا الذي بعث الله
رسولا ان كاد ليضلنا عن الهتنا لولا ان
صبرنا
عليها وسوف يعلمون حين يرون الع عذاب من
اضل
سبيلا ارايت من اتخذ الهه هواه
افانت تكون عليه
وكيلا ام تحسب
ان اكثرهم يسمعون او
يعقلون ان هم الا كالانعام بل هم اضل
سبيلا الم تر الى ربك كيف مد الظل ولو شاء
لجعله
ساكنا
ثم جعلنا الشمس عليه
دليلا
ثم قبضناه الينا قبضا
يسيرا وهو الذي جعل لكم الليل
لباسا
والنوم سبا
وجعل
النهار
نشورا وهو الذي ارسل الرياح بشرا بين يدي
رحمته
وانزلنا من
السماء
ماء
طهورا لنحيي به
بلده ميتا ونسقي
مما خلقنا
انعاما
واناسي
كثيرا ولقد صرفناه بينهم
ليذكروا فابى اكثر الناس الا
كفورا ولو شئنا لبعثنا في كل قريه
نذيرا فلا تطع
كفرين فلا تطع
الكافرين وجاهدهم
به
جهادا
كبيرا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الرحمن
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام
[Silence]
لام
‏make
‏requ fund
and
[Silence]
استقيم
اعتد
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وهو الذي مرج البحرين هذا عذب فرات
وهذا ملح
اجاج وجعل بينهما برزخا وحجرا
محجورا وهو الذي خلق من
الماء
بشرا فجعله نسبا
وصهرا وكان ربك قديرا ويعبدون من دون الله
ما لا ينفعهم ولا
يضرهم وكان الكافر على ربه
ظهيرا وما ارسلناك الا مبشرا ونذيرا
قل ما اسالكم عليه من اجر الا الا من شاا
ان يتخذ الى ربه
سبيلا وتوكل على الحي الذي لا
يموت وسبح بحمده وكفى به بذنوب عباده
خبيرا الذي خلق السماوات والارض وما
بينهما في سته
ايام في سته
ايام ثم استوى على
العرش الرحمن فاسال به
خبيرا واذا قيل لهم اسجدوا للرحمن قالوا
وما
الرحمن انسجد لما تامر نا وزادهم
نفورا الله
اكبر الله
اكبر تبارك الذي جعل في
السماء بروجا وجعل فيها وجعل فيها سراجا
وقمرا
منيرا وهو الذي جعل الليل والنهار خلفه
لمن
اراد لمن اراد ان يذكر او اراد
شكورا وعباد الرحمن الذين يمشون على الارض
هونا واذا خاطبهم الجاهل
قالوا
سلاما والذين يبيتون لربهم سجدا
وقياما والذين يقولون ربنا اصرف
عنا عذاب
جهنم
ان عذابها كان
غراما انها
ساءت م مقرا
ومقاما والذين اذا انفقوا لم يسرفوا ولم
يقتروا وكان بين ذلك
قواما والذين لا يدعون مع الله الها اخر
ولا
يقتلون ولا يقتلون النفس التي حرم الله
الا بالحق
ولا
يزنون ومن يفعل ذلك يلقى
اثاما يضاعف له العذاب يوم القيامه ويخلد
فيه
مهانا الا من تاب وامن وعمل
صالحا
فاولئك يبدل الله سيئات م
حسنات الا من تاب وامن وعمل
صالحا فاولئك
الا من تاب وامن وعمل عملا صالحا فاولئك
فاولئك يبدل الله
سيئاتهم
حسنات وكان الله غفورا رحيم
ومن تاب وعمل صالحا فانه يتوب الى الله
متابا والذين لا يشهدون الزور واذا مروا
باللغو مروا
كراما والذين اذا ذكروا بايات ربهم لم
يخروا عليها
صما
عميانا والذين يقولون ربنا هب لنا من
ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين وجعلنا
للمتقين
اماما
اولئك يجزون الغرفه بما
صبروا
ويلقون فيها
تحيه و
سلاما خالدين فيها حسنت
مستقرا
ومقاما قل ما يعبا بكم ربي لولا
دعاؤكم فقد كذبتم فسوف يكون
لزاما الله
اك
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين طا
سين
م تلك ايات التاب المبين لعلك باخع نفسك
الا يكونوا
مؤمنين
انشان نزل عليهم من
السماء ايه فظلت اعناقهم لها
خاضعين وما ياتيهم من
ذكر من الرحمن محدث الا كانوا عن عنه
معرضين فقد كذبوا فسوف ياتيهم
انباء ما كانوا به
يستهزئون اولم يروا الى الارض كم انبتنا
فيها من كل زوج كريم
ان في ذلك
لايه وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم واذ نادى ربك
موسى ان ائت القوم
الظالمين قوم فرعون الا
يتقون قال رب
اني اخاف ان
يكذبون ويضيق صدري ولا ينطلق لساني فار
الى هارون ولهم علي
ذنب فاخاف ان
يقتلون قال كلا فاذهبا انا معكم
مستمعون قال كلا فاذهبا
باياتنا انا معكم
مستمعون فات يا فرعون فقولا انا رسول رب
العالمين ان ارسل معنا بني
اسرائيل قال الم نربك فينا
وليدا ولبثت فينا من عمرك سنين وفعلت
فعلتك التي فعلت
وانت من
الكافرين قال فعلتها
اذا
قال فعلتها
اذا وانا من
الضالين ففررت منكم لما
خفتكم فوهب لي ربي حكما وجعلني من
المرسلين وتلك نعمه
تمنها علي ان عبدت بني
اسرائيل
قال فرعون وما رب
العالمين قال رب السماوات والارض وما
بينهما قال رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما
ان
كنتم
موقنين قال لمن حوله الا
تستمعون قال ربكم ورب اباء
ئكم
الاولين قال لئن اتخذت الها غيري
لاجعلنك
لاجعلنك من
المسجونين قال ان رسولكم الذي ارسل اليكم
لمجنون قال رب المشرق والمغرب وما بينهما
ان كنت كنتم
تعقلون قال لئن اتخذت الها غيري
لاجعلنك من
المسجونين قال اولو جئت اولو جئتك بشيء
مبين قال فات به ان كنت من
الصادقين فالقى عصاه فاذا هي
ثعبان مبين ونزع يده فاذا هي
بيضاء
للناظرين قال لمن حوله ان هذا لساحر
عليم قال قال للملا حوله ان
هذا ان هذا
لساحر مبين يريد لساحر عليم يريد ان
يخرجكم من ارضكم بسحره فماذا
تامرون قالوا ارجه واخاه وابعث في
المدائن
حاشرين ياتوك بكل سحار
عليم فجمع السحره لميقات يوم معلوم وقيل ل
الناس هل
انتم
مجتمعون لعلنا نتبع السحره ان كانوا هم
الغالبون ان كانوا هم
الغالبين
فلما جاء السحره قالوا
لفرعون قالوا لفرعون اان لنا لاجرا ان كنا
نحن
الغالبين قال نعم
وانكم اذا لمن
المقربين قال موسى قال لهم موسى القوا ما
انتم
ملقون فالقوا حبالهم
وعصيهم
وقالوا وقالوا بعزه فرعون انا لنحن
الغالبون
فالقى موسى عصاه فاذا هي تلقف ما
يافكون فالقي السحره
ساجدين قالوا
امنا برب
العالمين قالوا
العالمين رب موسى
وهارون قال امنتم له قبل ان اذن لكم
انه لكبيركم الذي علمكم
السحر فلسوف
تعلمون فل
لاقطعن ايديكم
وارجلكم من خلاف ولاصلبنكم
اجمعين قالوا لا
ضير
انا الى ربنا
منقلبون
انا نطمع ان يغفر لنا ربنا خطايانا
ان
كنا اول
المؤمنين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيم
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين واوحينا الى موسى ان اسر بعبادي
انكم
متبعون فارسل فرعون في
المدائن
حاشرين ان
هؤلاء
لشرم ق ليلون وانهم لنا
لغائظون
وانا لجميع
حاذرون
فاخرجناهم من
جنات
وعيون وكنوز
ومقام كريم كذلك
واورثناها بني
اسرائيل
فاتبعوهم مشرقين
فلما
تراء الجمعان قال اصحاب موسى انا
لمدركون قال كلا ان معي ربي
سيهدين فاوحينا الى موسى ان اضرب بعصاك
البحر
فانفلق فكان كل فرق كالطود
العظيم وازلفنا ثم الاخ قرين
وانجينا موسى ومن معه
اجمعين ثم اغرقنا
الاخرين ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم واتل عليهم نبا
ابراهيم اذ قال لابيه وقومه ما
تعبدون قالوا نعبد
اصناما فنظل لها عاكفين
قال هل
يسمعونكم اذ
تدعون او
ينفعونكم او
يضرون قالوا بل وجدنا
اباءنا كذلك
يفعلون قال
افرايتم ما كنتم تعب
انتم
واباؤكم
الاقدمون
فانهم عدو لي الا رب
العالمين الذي خلقني فهو يهدين والذي هو
يطعمني
ويسقين واذا مرضت فهو يشفين والذي يميتني
ثم
يحيين الذي اطمع ان يغفر لي
خطيئتي يوم الدين رب هب لي حكما والحقني
بالصالحين واجعل لي لسان صدق في
الاخرين واجعلني من ورثه جنه
النعيم واغفر لابي انه كان من
الضا
ين ولا تخزني يوم يبعثون يوم لا ينفع مال
ولا بنون الا من اتى الله بقلب سليم
وازلفت الجنه
للمتقين وبرزت الجحيم
للغاوين وقيل لهم اينما كنتم تعبدون من
دون الله هل
ينصرونكم او
ينتصرون فكبكبوا فيها هم
والغاوون وجنود ابليس
اجمعون قالوا وهم فيها
يختصمون ت الله ان كنا لفي ضلال مبين اذ
نسويكم برب
العالمين وما اضلنا الا المجرمون فما لنا
من
شافعين ولا صديق حميم فلو ان لنا كره
فنكون من
المؤمنين ان في ذلك
لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز الر
رحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين كذبت قوم نوح
المرسلين اذ قال لهم اخوهم نوح الا
تتقون اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري
الا على رب
العالمين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون قالوا انؤمن لك واتبع ك
الارذلون قال وما علمي بما كانوا
يعملون ان حسابهم الا على ربي لو
تشعرون وما انا بطارد المؤمنين ان انا الا
نذير
مبين قالوا لئن لم تنتهي يا نوح
لتكونن من
المرجومين قال رب ان قومي كذبون فافتح
بيني وبينهم فتحا ونجني ومن معي من
المؤمنين
فانجيناه ومن معه في الفلك المشحون ثم
اغرقنا بعد
الباقين ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين
وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم كذبت عاد المرسلين اذ قال لهم
اخوهم هود الا تتقون اني لكم رسول امين
فاتقوا الله
واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري
الا على رب
العالمين اتبنون بكل ريع ايه تعبثون
وتتخذون مصانع لعلكم
تخلدون وتتخذون مصانع لعلكم
تخلدون واذا بطشتم بطشتم
جبارين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون واتقوا الذي امدكم بما
تعلمون امد كم بانعام وبنين
وجنات
وعيون اني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم
عظيم قالوا
سواء علينا اوعظت ام لم تكن من
الواعظين ان هذا الا خلق الاولين وما نحن
بمعذبين
فكذبوه فاهلك هم ان في ذلك لايه وما كان
اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم كذبت ثمود المرسلين اذ قال لهم
اخوهم صالح الا
تتقون اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري
الا على رب
العالمين اتتركون فيما هاه
امنين في
جنات وعيون وزروع ونخل طلعها هضيم وتنحتون
من الجبال بيوتا
فارهين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون ولا تطيعوا امر المسرفين
الذين يفسدون في الارض ولا
يصلحون قالوا انما انت من
المسحرين ما انت الا بشر مثلنا فات بايه
ان كنت من
الصادقين قال هذه ناقه لها شرب ولكم شرب
يوم
معلوم ولا تمسوها
بسوء فياخذ عذاب يوم عظيم فعقروها
فاصبحوا
نادمين فاخذهم
العذاب ان في ذلك لايه وما كان
اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو
العزيز
رحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم صلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى
اله وصحبه ومن ولاه ومن تبع باحسان اليوم
الدين اما
بعد عليه
واللام
[Silence]
عليه
لاملام
[Silence]
‏first
‏me in mind are just guesses could be
is inone so we take as of come up the
first indicate صل
علم dre it hour
theate
in and
us
‏dream dream
mind عليه
[Silence]
الصلام
comm
that
عليه
‏other
[Silence]
ug
عليه
لام some is something that i personally
age
with
الله
[Silence]
صليه
‏are
things
‏trans
عليه
يهان
[Silence]
ض
الله
خض
عن
الله
[Silence]
اناليه
محال نا اتنا فين حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا عب
جنم وقنا عتنه وقنا عبته المسيح الدجال
ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع العليم وتوب
علينا يا مولانا التواب الرحيم صلى الله
على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك
ارحم الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم امين
اللهم
امين
استقيم الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذ صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ين
امين كذبت قوم لوط
المرسلين اذ قال لهم اخوهم لوط الا
تتقون اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري
الا على رب
العالمين اتاتون الذكران من
العالمين وتذرون ما خلق لكم ربكم من
ازواجكم بل انتم قوم
عادون قالوا لئن لم تنتهي يا لوط
لتكونن من
المخرجين قال اني لعملكم من
القالين ربنا نجني واهلي مما
يعملون فنجيناه واهله
اجمعين الا عجوزا في
الغابرين ثم دمرنا
الاخرين وامطرنا عليهم مطرا
فساء مطر
المنذرين ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم كذب اصحاب الايكه
المرسلين اذ قال لهم شعيب الا
تتقون اني لكم رسول
امين فاتقوا الله واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه
من اجر ان اجري الا على رب العالمين
اوفوا الكيل ولا تكونوا من المخسرين
وزنوا بالقسطاس
المستقيم ولا تبخسوا الناس
اشياءهم ولا تعثوا في الارض
مفسدين واتقوا الذي خلقكم والجب ل
الاولين قالوا انما انت من
المسحرين وما انت الا بشر مثلنا وان نظنك
لمن
الكاذبين فاسقط علينا كسفا من
السماء ان كنت من
الصادقين قال ربي اعلم بما
تعملون فكذبوه فاخذهم عذاب يوم فكذبوه
فاخذهم عذاب يوم الظله
انه كان عذاب يوم عظيم ان في ذلك لايه وما
كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وانه لتنزيل رب
العالمين نزل به الروح الامين على قلبك
لتكون من
المنذرين بلسان عربي مبين وانه لفي زبر
الاولين اولم يكن لهم ايه ان يعلمه
علماء بني
اسرائيل ولو نزلناه على بعض
الاعجمين فقرا عليهم ما كانوا به
مؤمنين كذلك سلكناه في قلوب
المجرمين لا يؤمنون به حتى يروا العذاب
الاليم
فياتيهم بغته وهم لا
يشعرون فيقولوا هل نحن
منظرون افبعذابنا
يستعجلون افرايت ان متعناهم سنين ثم
جاءهم ما كانوا يوعدون ما اغنى عنهم ما
كانوا
يمتعون وما اهلكنا من قريه الا لها
منذرون ذكرى وما كنا
ظالمين وما تنزلت به
الشياطين وما ينبغي لهم وما
يستطيعون انهم عن السمع لمعزولون
فلا تدع مع الله الها اخر فتكون من
المعذبين وانذر عشيرتك
الاقربين واخفض جناحك لمن اتبعك من
المؤمنين فان عصوك فقل اني
بريء
مما
تعملون وتوكل على العزيز رحيم الذي يراك
حين
تقوم وتقلبك في
الساجدين انه هو السميع العليم هل انبئكم
على من تنزل
الشياطين تنزل على كل افاك
اثيم يلقون السمع واكثرهم
كاذبون
والشعراء يتبعهم
الغاوون الم تر انهم في كل واد
يهيمون وانهم يقولون ما لا
يفعلون الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وذكروا الله كثيرا
وانتصروا
وانتصروا من بعد ما ظلموا وسيعلم الذين ظ
لم اي
منقلب
ينقلبون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
استقيم سجد تلا اسرك ان شاء
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحم رحم الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
طا
سين تلك ايات القران وكتاب مبين هدى وبشرى
للمؤمنين الذين يقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون
الزكاه وهم بالاخره هم
يوقنون ان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره زينا
لهم اعمالهم فهم يعمهون
اولئك الذين لهم سوء العذاب وهم في الاخره
هم
الاخسرون وانك لتلقى القران من لدن حكيم
عليم اذ قال موسى لاهله اني انست نارا
ساتيكم منها بخبر او اتيكم
بشهاب قبس
ساتيكم منها بخبر او اتيكم بشهاب قبس
لعلكم
تصطلون فلما
جاءها نودي ان بورك من في النار ومن حولها
وسبحان الله رب
العالمين يا موسى اني انا الله العزيز
الحكيم والق عصاك فلما راها تهتز كانها
جان ولا مدبرا ولم
يعقب يا موسى لا تخف اني لا يخاف لدي
المرسلون الا من ظلم ثم بدل حسنا بعد
سوء فاني غفور
رحيم وادخل يدك في جيبك تخرج
بيضاء من غير
سوء في تسع ايات الى فرعون وقومه انهم
كانوا قوما
فاسقين فلما
جاءتهم اياتنا
مبصره قالوا هذا سحر مبين وجحدوا بها
واستيقنتها
انفسهم ظلما
وعلوا فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
المفسدين ولقد اتينا داوود وسليمان علما
وقال الحمد لله الذي فضلنا على كثير من
عباده
المؤمنين وورث سليمان داوود وقال يا ايها
الناس علمنا منطق الطير واوتينا من كل
شيء ان هذا لهو الفضل المبين وحشر لسليمان
جنوده من الجن والانس والطير فهم
يوزعون حتى اذا اتوا على واد النمل قالت
نمله يا ايها النمل ادخلوا مس سكنكم لا
يحطمنكم سليمان
وجنوده قالت نمله يا ايها النمل ادخلوا
مساكنكم لا
يحطمنكم سليمان وجنوده وهم لا
يشعرون فتبسم
ضاحكا من قولها وقال رب اوزعني ان اشكر
نعمتك التي انعمت علي وعلى
والدي وان اعمل صالحا
ترضاه وادخلني برحمتك في عبادك
الصالحين وتفقد الطير فقال مالي لا ارى
الهدهد ام كان من
الغائبين
لاعذبنه
عذابا شديدا او لاذ حنه او
لياتين
بسلطان
مبين فمكث غير بعيد فقال احطت بما لم تحط
به وجئتك من سبا
بنبا
يقين اني وجدت امراه تملكهم واوتيت من كل
شيء ولها عرش عظيم وجدتها وقومها يسجدون
للشمس من دون الله وزين لهم الشيطان
اعمالهم وزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فصدهم
عن السبيل فهم لا
يهتدون الا يسجدوا لله الذي يخرج الخبا في
السماوات والارض ويعلم ما تخفون وما
تعلنون الله لا اله الا هو رب العرش
العظيم الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
قال سننظر اصدقت ام
كنت من
الكاذبين اذهب بكتابي هذا فالقه اليهم ثم
تول عنهم فانظر ماذا
يرجعون قالت يا ايها الملا اني القي الي
كتاب كريم انه من سليمان وانه بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم الا تعلوا علي الا تعلوا
علي
واتوني
مسلمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ضالين
امين قالت يا ايها الملا افتوني في امري
ما كنت قاطعه امرا حتى
تشهدون قالوا نحن اولو قوه والو باس شديد
والامر اليك فانظري ماذا
تامرين قالت ان الملوك اذا دخلوا قريه
افسدوها وجعلوا اعزه اهلها اذله وكذلك
يفعلون واني مرسله اليهم بهديه فناظر بم
يرجع
المرسلون فلما
جاء سليمان قال اتمد ني
بمال فما اتاني الله خير مما اتاكم بل
انتم بهديتكم
تفرحون ارجع اليهم
فلناتينهم
بجنود لا قبل لهم بها ولنخرجنهم
منها اذله وهم
صاغرون قال يا ايها الملا ايكم ياتيني
بعرشها قبل ان ياتوني
مسلمين قال عفريت من الجن انا اتيك به قبل
ان تقوم من مقامك واني عليه لقوي
امين قال الذي عنده علم من الكتاب انا
اتيك به قبل ان يرتد اليك طرفك فلما راه
مستقرا عنده قال هذا من فضل ربي ليبلوني
ااشكر ام اكفر ومن شكر فانما يشكر لنفسه
ومن كفر فان ربي غني
كريم قال نكروا لها عرشها ننظر اتهتدي ام
تكون من الذين لا
يهتدون فلما جاء
سليم فلما
جاءت قيل اهكذا عرشك قالت كانه هو واوتينا
العلم من قبلها وكنا
مسلمين وصدها ما كانت تعبد من دون الله
انها كانت من قوم كافرين
قيل لها ادخل الصرح فلما راته حسبته لجه
وكشفت عن
ساقيها قال انه صرح ممرد من
قوارير قالت رب اني ظلمت نفسي واسلمت مع
سليمان لله رب
العالمين ولقد ارسلنا الى ثمود اخاهم
صالحا ان اعبدوا الله فاذا هم فريقان
يختصمون قال يا قوم لم تستعجلون بالسيئه
قبل الحسنه لولا تستغفرون الله لعلكم
ترحمون قالوا اطيرنا بك وبمن معك قال
طائركم عند الله بل انتم قوم
تفتنون وكان في المدينه تسعه رهط يفسدون
في الارض ولا
يصلحون قالوا تقاسموا بالله لنبيتنه
واهله ثم
لنقولن لوليه ما شهدنا مهلك اهله وانا
لصادقون ومكروا مكرا ومكرنا مكرا وهم لا
يشعرون فانظر كيف كان عاقبه مكرهم انا
دمرناهم وقومهم
اجمعين فتلك بيوتهم خاويه بما ظلموا ان في
ذلك لايه لقوم
يعلمون
وانجينا الذين امنوا وكانوا يت
تقون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
مستقيم الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد وا اياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين كلا اذا دكت الارض دكا دكا
وجاء ربك والملك صفا صفا
وجيء يومئذ بجهنم
يومئذ يتذكر الانسان
وانا له
الذكرى يقول يا ليتني قدمت
لحياتي فيومئذ لا يعذب عذابه احد ولا يوثق
وث
احد يا ايتها النفس
المطمئنه ارجعي الى ربك
راضيه مرضيه فادخلي في عبادي وادخلي
جنتي الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا زلزلت الارض زلزالها واخرجت
الارض
اثقالها وقال
الانسان ما لها يومئذ تحدث
اخبارها يومئذ تحدث اخبارها بان ربك اوحى
لها يومئذ يصدر الناس اشتاتا ليروا
اعمالهم فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا يره ومن
يعمل مثقال ذره
شرا يره الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد اللهم اغننا بحلالك عن حرام
اللهم اكفنا بحلالك عن حرامك واغننا بفضلك
عمن
سواك اللهم اكفنا بحلالك عن حرامك واغننا
بفضلك عمن سواك اللهم انا نسالك التقى
والهدى والعفاف والغنى اللهم انا نسالك
التقى والهدى والعفاف
والغنى اللهم انا نسالك التقى والهدى
والعفاف
والغنى اللهم احسن
خواتيمنا ووفقنا لما تحب وترضى اللهم اغفر
لنا
ولابائنا
ولاها تنا ولاصحاب الحقوق علينا واغفر
للمؤمنين والمؤمنات
والمسلمين والمسلمات احياء
وامواتا اللهم انا نسالك العفو والعافيه
في الدنيا
الاخره ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار اللهم بلغنا
ليله القدر واجعلنا من عتقائك من النار
ومن
المقبولين اللهم فرج كرب اخواننا في غزه
والسودان وفي كل مكان اللهم اطعمهم من جو
وامنهم من خوف اللهم انتقم من
المتجبرين اللهم اقتلهم بددا واحصهم عددا
ولا تذر منهم احدا انهم يا رب لا يعجزونك
وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام السلام
عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
اي
المسانه انا الله العزيز
الحيا